a local woman sharing exclusively with
eight news now the loitering that goes
on right behind her backyard wall yeah
it's right near the target along Decatur
and the 215 after getting nowhere with
property managers she's now getting
police involved Madison Kimbrough with
the story
Maria Echols home is just over this wall
and as you can see she put up this sign
in hopes that it would deter the
loitering that's been happening in this
parking lot that's adjacent to her
property people getting high I've seen
exchanges of sales
of drugs I don't want that behind my
home I'm retired now I'm medically
retired and
this is scary
it's scary because people don't care
Maria Eccles sharing with eight news now
what she sees through her windows on a
daily basis her bedroom window sits high
up in plain view of the indecent
Behavior she says happens behind her
backyard wall I've seen the middle age
people come here and meet up
some of them in their Company Vans
um meeting up with whomever
but
this is a constant go to a hotel or
motel whatever but don't do this behind
people's homes Eccles installing
floodlights a no loitering sign and
security cameras to deter these people
but says it's a constant disturbance the
alleged incidents are happening on the
property of a Target located in the
shopping center near Decatur and 215.
echol says she's reached out to the
store management team but I spoke with a
Target employee last week and she was
basically like she she told me it's not
our problem I'm angry because
with the community that supports you
so do better by the community that
supports you Target off and on has
security coming through here at night
but you know you're not addressing
what's going on during the day as for
what's next Eccles filed a police report
hoping law enforcement would step in and
stop this from happening we spoke to
others in the area as well they declined
to go on camera but acknowledge the
problem even expressing that the thought
of moving has crossed their minds is
public indecency public lewdness behind
people's homes and all of us are fed up
some good news on the horizon I reached
out to Brixton Capital the commercial
Realtors who leased the property and
they told me they plan on upping
Security on the premises particularly
during the daytime when these acts occur
reporting in the North Valley Madison
Kimbrough 8 news now the management
company also stating that they are fully
aware of the situation and have already
added more no trespassing signs as a
deterrent